what's up everybody whip on Finity since  you guys really enjoy the episode with  the bouncy ball we're gonna do a full  video on it  [Music]  yeah you feet  [Music]  for  Oh Norway  [Music]  and guys we still have the challenge to  reach 200k subscribers by the end of  this year  so please remember the subscribe  [Music]  haha  [Music]  Alexandra  [Music]  Oh  [Music]  [Music]  ah no  try to get that one  [Music]  all right let's see how many thumbs  we're gonna tease back and forth over  the net  that's it  four five six seven oh seven [ __ ] that  and that  [Music]  [Music]  winner  [Music]  Rolla every more ways for me tax  watching guys remember subscribe here  and check out previous episodes there  until next time